hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica now I've
got a lot of work to do but don't you
worry your pretty little head I won't
show you nothing that ain't ain't worth
seeing which is more likely to be this
like that so I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
get to gathering but soon we're gonna
actually have to go back to the Aurora
because somebody said and this may be in
the development mode but I'm not armed
as in sure but someone by the name of I
don't have the last job oh god rabbi joy
come on by the name of Xylo fuse said
there's a room in the aurora with a data
terminal and on this data terminal are
blueprints to a rocket ship now if you
may have been watching the most recent
charity stream I came across this
conundrum is device thanks Aaron I know
I'm dying Ally it's just a fact of my
life and existence so you can just let
me be me thank you very much okay I'm
gonna go do that I guess [ __ ] care
and all its caring about me says why
your name is Devin thing that adversity
[Music]
kind of [ __ ] is but okay something's
trying to get in hey what's up [ __ ] is
that is happening Barry what the [ __ ] is
happening to you okay I think I think
maybe big box Barry might be a little
haunted good what the [ __ ] okay I'm
gonna pretend like everything it's
perfectly normal here
and that wasn't absolutely regarde damn
dick ulis so don't worry about that
welcome I'll worry about that and then
I'm going to go come on and get more
materials because I'm starting to fill
up these things I've got a boatload of
titanium here I've got another boatload
here I've got a whole bunch there but
it's not enough I tell you I'm gonna go
get a whole lot heck in a lot of them
more and then we got a lot of what I'll
do is I need to get to it quickly and
without delay
I'm gonna do exactly that but some is
about the balls it does it but I am
shopping titanium into you to be able to
be able to be able to be able to be able
to be able to be a bit boring
okay we're full up there okay with this
all right
just oh I'm making something okay and we
fish we have the ability to go up to a
modification station wherever we need to
go which is good because I don't know
why I'm not under than sure I forgot why
I needed this I am completely and
utterly forgot why I needed this why did
I build this goddamn thing in my goddamn
face
alright ok welcome back I'd smoke
outside [ __ ] what the [ __ ] was bad
what the [ __ ] was bad [ __ ] you god damn
it ok
alright that's how we're gonna be huh
that was exciting anyway I got more
let's read I guess [ __ ] okay so - Kirby
trouser because in the Tuck says alright
let's help mark out here's a big list of
important tasks before your final
spelunking you need to move your
laboratories and get some Mellon plants
which I'll get in the floating island
later and you need to grab their
creepvine and coral samples which i
think i can grow creepvine inside my
base which i forgot about that you need
to relocate the modification and
important machines to the Cyclops which
I just did I mean you must reinforce
your diving gear which I might do I like
living dangerously that's kind of like
money that's kind of like my specialty
right now but right now I'm going to
build something amazing because I got
some copper over here and with this
copper I'm going to make the most
amazing structures that you've ever seen
oh yes [ __ ] forgot I did silicone that's
right I'm an idiot gotta go get silicon
[ __ ] I'm out of water oh my life is hell
what is what is doing that
why keep smoking BAE I don't like it
sobbing these are the ghost of my dead
children of all big box berries on
father children they're giving again me
okay
so just calm down everything's okay it's
the mysterious ghost problem happening
inside my base but that's okay so I need
to get mr. Fester back in base unless
that is mr. Fisher banging up a storm
out there which you might be because
he's a little bit of a security baby who
he got out of place to go
we're gonna get in here we need some
free pine anyways your mother's [ __ ]
hold on I don't exactly know what that
[ __ ] is but I'm gonna go get it actually
you know what I could do that I bet I
bet I bet [ __ ] god damn it stop it I
bet I've got my Seaguar what am i
hitting what am i hitting anyway I got
my see glide back in my original base
ooh the Aurora's got a new decoration on
the top of the tent but anyway I've got
my my see glide back in my original base
not my life bar boat but the original
base that I said goodbye to and boy
that's gonna be an uncomfortable reunion
if I go back to that base but you know
to each his own I guess
I guess we can do that why not so away
we go I need to stop by creepvine forest
first and then I can go try to find my c
glide I don't know where it is a man
taking it back to my base down in the
deep depths but I need to go back there
anyway because I'm going to give me some
marble Mellon to be able to make some
more potted plants in here so I'm not
just chomping down Lantern fruit over
and over again that way I can actually
get some good nutrition in my body
before I die a horrible death down the
lava zone then I can reinforce all my
[ __ ] then I can make new bad
then I'll be good but until then I'm not
good I won't be good until I find this
stuff that I do need so who's gonna give
me some glowing Lantern stuff not
Lantern stuff Sanskrit vine clusters and
then I need creepvine sample because I'm
pretty sure silicon is actually made
maybe's enough maybe that's not silicon
either way I need a lot of this [ __ ]
here so I'm gonna go get that I'm gonna
dive in without any perception that's
how I roll
oh no we're getting full up all right
here we go this is so scary
I give give give you keep Russian give
give give Jeff Jeff Jeff Jeff Jeff Jeff
Jeff if I'm fired by fault don't do that
to me
geez it tells a weird sound okay but
anyway I made that so hopefully I put my
goddamn titanium away because I'm
goddamn goof but if I get my titanium
again I should be able to get what I
need to get and then build some of these
planter pots and then maybe just maybe
what the ingredients unknown do you mean
by that what what did I make that out of
well yeah that's it word I have no idea
what the hell dad what okay whatever you
know what I'm not gonna worry about that
so I don't think yeah I don't think I
can make it in that one but I do think I
can make it in the indoor grow bed so if
I put this y'all it's glow blue ski and
I put this ah no I can't do that
no if I would be able to okay so I can't
do that it's fine it's fine whatever I
don't
need is or anything so I can't make that
I'm pretty sure that's probably an
exterior Grove edit that makes that
thing which is kind of good I can't
build that in here yeah that is isn't it
okay but either way I should be able to
take these creep fine seeds down into
the depths and they should be able to
plant some stuff right that's the idea
oh and also I'm gonna make more lockers
because I can because I actually do have
a surplus of materials and I actually am
finding myself in need of more storage
because I do have all these different
things that are going to be blocking me
down so I can make some more of these
and I can more names on the lockers and
hopefully down the road I'll be able to
do that again because it was like my
favorite thing to be able to do this
got it okay so family for now so I'm
going to put new names in the locker
first up was uh Xylo fuse for giving me
the suggestion to the blueprints on the
rocket ship and then there was two Kirby
rods is mater and then okay that's there
so that's good who said all the list of
the improvements that I needed and then
there was cookie darts who said to bring
back bumble but and I'm gonna do exactly
that a hundred percent no way I'm not
going to do that and then there's Grom
underscore oh nine one one who said
build a frickin thermometer already if
you won't do it in the beginning in the
next video I don't know what I will do
with you which sounds vaguely like a
threat and if there's anything that will
get me to put your name on Locker
it's a vaguely veiled threat okay so I
need to make silicon rubber with this
I'm only gonna be able to make three
this far but that's good enough because
that's going to be a good enough start
and then I'm gonna be able to make the
ion power cells and then I'm going to be
able to switch those out in terms of my
power cells up there and that's going to
give me an unbelievable boost in terms
of the power that I'm going to create
twenty 3ds 3ds that'll do and I'm gonna
have those I'll be able to make ah ion
power cells oh yeah baby give me that
power I don't know how much power is
gonna be I need to perfect
okay a little greedy on that don't you
think a little greedy but okay I'll do
whatever you tell me to do
all right then another one kill ya give
me what I need and then blue definitely
good to put the power of a nuke inside
of a Power Cell inside of my only boat
that's going to go down to a lava
infused zone and probably overheat and
blow everything up there it seems good
damn oh wow wow that's a lot of power
holy [ __ ]
that doubled my power that's slipping
doubled my power oh my god I wanted to
use every single other ion crystal I
have I could make more of those woo is
tempting is real tempting but I just
don't know should I should I spend my
last ion cells on that I mean actually
go find there are more alien caches out
in the world and I could find them
that's not a bad idea that's not a bad
idea I could go out and find them okay
so here are every single location for
the alien caches the precursor base
there's one in the sparse reef which I
think I visited there's one in the blood
kelp Zone which I don't think I've
visited I've definitely visited the one
in the dunes there's one in the
laboratory in the Lost River which I
have I have visited because that's the
one by the big skeleton
there's the teleporters one in the
mushroom forest and one in the Koosh
zone and I don't think I've been to
those I may not have been the boat I may
have been to the one in the couch zone
but I'm pretty sure I've never been to
the one in the mushroom forest because
I've never even heard of that so I
wonder what I'm closest to let me look
up this this isn't a cheating menu this
is just debug menu so I'm by I'm at 250
negative 50 and negative 400 so that
means I'm 50 meters deep and then my x
and y are not very close to anything
I'm gonna go to the coos because that's
actually right near where I need to be
and also I need more of these creep line
samples I'm definitely gonna need more
of these creepvine seeds I sure do love
going out in the dark like this good boy
ah fun grade yes lots of fun okay [ __ ]
he's out there that's probably enough
I feel more power than I'm ever going to
need my entire existence
I've got enough creepvine to last me
forever with those creep line seeds once
I'm able to build my base down in the
lava zone I'm going to be able to fill
it with creepvine and get as much
creepvine and creep under sneezes as I
need which is good oh hey buddy
oh I'm still at the ass-end of you
perfer time I didn't even realize that I
do need to make it still suit that is
another thing that I do need to make if
I make this fill suit then that's gonna
help me because then I'm going to be ah
[ __ ] and beached get over there oh hello
where am I okay I think I'm moving so if
I make it still suit then I'm not going
to I'm not going to worry about just as
much water I'm going to be able to drink
my own piss which is something that L
has always been an ambition of mine and
then I want to be able to do that and I
don't know where I'm going with this but
I'm gonna be able to do I'm gonna be
able to drink my own piss is pretty much
what I'm saying I'll see you at my old
base oh hi Hey
how's it going oh my god it's been so
long oh no I thought I'd say goodbye to
you forever
Oh caring of this one you're still here
oh you're so cool I mean not really in
all that stuff but you know you're kind
of cool
oh so which one of you had my goddamn
sea glide I know I know I'm gonna need
it eventually
hmm you got a lot of [ __ ] here but
not everything that I need oh it's spicy
light in all my dead batteries which I
don't need anymore because I got special
Amazo batteries but if I drop stuff off
in here this is a whole bunch of
[ __ ] here so if I just start
dropping stuff off me get some typing
eMac okay all right that's good for that
man blow and blip blop okay that's
actually going to be good for us then I
just go grab my see glide I'm gonna pop
this bad ass battery in this and it
ain't never ever gonna run out of things
that I need for someone get everything
else I need hey you got anything in here
jokes for days jokes for days added of
course he did okay so that's good
got my seat glide with my utils of power
I can actually have my C glide and
wander around the ocean without worrying
about being caught with my pants down
and then I can make the charge fins that
are going to be able to charge it as
they go along it's going to be amazing
do I even have charged fins I don't I
don't have any sort of upgraded fins why
didn't I do that I can get a wiring kit
what is awesome what didn't I do this
sooner
oh this is amazing so I get the wiring
kit I get the charge fins I'm gonna put
this freakin battery in the goddamn seat
line and then whoa
500 and then I'll never run out of power
because I got a battery charger for this
bad boy in my goddamn Cyclops free here
oh do CLE yeah oh my god oh and then I
need a fence okay so I take these off
fabricated drawers from the available
data to provide environment appropriate
equipment using locally available
materials for your safety this setting
cannot be overridden oh thanks
alrighty then
bloob Oh so these are swim charge fins
so these will charge the equipment that
I'm holding as I swim now I won't charge
it over the point where uses it I don't
think anyway but what it will do is
it'll use oh that's so good 498 power I
didn't even think I used it apparently
it drained a little bit of power there
just because it was so goddamn excited
about it so what I'm going to do is I'm
actually gonna make one more spare
battery because I can and why not so I'm
gonna make another spare battery of the
ion crystal variety and then I'm gonna
have all the power I ever need in my
entire life and that he's phenomenal
that he's phenomena the only problem is
that it takes up a huge space in my
inventory which is not good also I think
it's a yeah was probably the probably
flashlight that was doing it okay so
this is going really well he's doing
really astonishingly well I'm really
happy about this so the last thing that
I'm gonna do in this particular episode
is I'm going to find the Koosh zone
alien cache and I believe that's gonna
be right over this way okay woo hello I
know it sounds about we are approaching
the couch zone we are full of coos baby
if I remember the couch what the coos
like an extremely water filled thing
maybe I can plan some kushma you think
maybe I can plan some of this here Koosh
maybe how me a good old time down in the
lava zone I'm gonna make a pit stop here
and I'm gonna do well there's the
wreckage though
walk it out hey what the [ __ ] man
somebody doing that we're doing your my
boat with the [ __ ] oh god damn it
sobbing I don't want to go out that door
excuse the voice cry all got a brave I'm
a brave boy I will go down there Fred
after I save I got my we go [ __ ] City
whoa [ __ ] what is that what's happening
wasn't you where's your home [ __ ] hi
hello again are you doing friend all
right oh [ __ ]
Iran is in again large organic mass let
me scan this I guess yes weird and cushy
is Fox hi
okay hi hello hi I don't know what the
[ __ ] is happening
who's Bush great sweet coos fish ice if
I remember correctly this is edible
and it gives a lot of water so maybe I
know it's probably not gonna be a
hundred percent sure but by [ __ ] high
oh [ __ ] you're a scary scary I don't
know what the for example
good get 100% ain't good so if I get got
some titanium here if I build another
grow bed maybe right I can do it there
look what I got I know what I got a
message who's giving me a message is it
the ghost is it the ghost is it the
ghost it's ghost visited okay so that
doesn't work so I can't grow it there
that's okay because with this couch I'm
pretty sure I should be able to put this
into like an aquarium or another grow
bed so I'm gonna keep it I'm gonna keep
some of it I'm going to eat the rest of
it okay I'm gonna keep that that's gonna
be good back who the [ __ ] is sending me
a message
cuz that that's not supposed to happen
that doesn't happen anymore I guess I
could make another wiring kit and do
that but I'm running out of silver I'm
gonna have to get more from the dunes
before I go back down but you know what
why not [ __ ] do this I gotta make a
wiring kit Jesus ye great hello who's
there somebody somebody want to talk to
me I guess is right on the right by my
here we go it's a good place for it line
up that dot right there that's good yeah
that's good high priority automated
message from Aurora life pod 13
coordinates attached life pod contains
last zone remains and passenger emissary
jokey Kassar I said jokey Kassar why do
I have to record this anyway send
immediate burial detail what sent
immediate burial detail
but what mongolian emissary why did i
just get that okay he is far away why is
he so far away I've never even heard of
that lifepod okay I'll get to that later
that is a goddamn huge piece of crash
debris I don't even think I've seen that
anymore either way I'm getting close to
where I need to go I'm not gonna go
there yet I'm not gonna go see emissary
jokey Kassar but I've never seen this
one have I know this isn't the same one
that I've seen before it might be
something on here that I could use I
don't know what but there might be so
let me just I might do my due diligence
and I'm gonna go into this one because I
don't recall seeing one in the Koosh
zone I've got my super spooky doodle
least I'll go a little bit faster yeah
all right then if you want to be all
honest about it that's fine too
mice can any of you ah toss it high oh
Jesus is a scary one alright let's open
you push okay all right then
walk okay I feel like there's nothing
good in here
only death yeah mama leave
participation
if I want to do this god that's a lot of
scary noises happening out there more
than I've used to but I like it alright
whatever it's fine it's all good all
good
what do we got ah PDA good okay
download the Charter all right whatever
already that when I get out of this
hellhole god damn it
yeah give me give me give me give me
home
give me home give me home give me home
oh boy oh boy what the [ __ ] was that
what the [ __ ] something just pushed me
well to the whole within a goddamn ghost
hold on this goddamn ghost wasn't it a
ghost push me I don't like that I don't
like that okay carrying on ah okay so
this this cache can currently be found
in an incomplete state but there is no
cache present yet it is in development
here so we got that it's a little bit of
a disappointment but we did get some
couch here which has a lot of water
which means that when we build our base
if we're able to plant food we should be
good and if we can eventually down below
if you remember there was a teleporter
down there and maybe just maybe that's
going to be able to get us onto the
surface a little easier and we have
before so that is all for this episode
we accomplished quite a bit I got
everything I needed and we've been
scared the hell out of the entire time
we've been here and I don't know why
ghost keeps haunting my goddamn boat by
the ghost of Larry Lester I guess trying
to Klaus way back from the afterlife but
either way that's all the time I got
some thank you everybody so much for
watching if you want to get your name on
the locker or and someone is pointed out
I can also put people's names on [ __ ]
why
what that [ __ ] rat about why did you
just do that
god dammit name place
why
anyway so I guess I'm done here thank
you everybody so much for watching hope
you guys enjoyed this let me know how I
didn't count down below I might pick
your name for one lockers or a nameplate
if I find that panda as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye
[Music]